coffee and tea are not the main
attractions at a growing number of
Japanese cafes their patrons also get to
spend quality time with birds
rabbits penguins and other creatures and
while the animals may be tamed the
competition among these cafes is growing
fierce as the list of animal playmates
gets ever more exotic Lucy craft has the
story from Tokyo Tokyo is synonymous
with hipster cafes but at this posh
establishment admission is by
reservation only and there's a one month
waiting list Tokyo has gone hog-wild for
the my pig cafe starring a herd of micro
pigs $13 buys you half an hour with the
squealing creatures puffing over from
her native Canada tourists Mercedes
[ __ ] was in what else hog heaven with
mini pigs bringing home the bacon
co-founder Yuji miyagawa has two more
porcine cafes in the works we really
want to sell the image that figures are
not dirty din of lead and not dumb
they're really smart clean and really
adoring animals ever since cat cafes
sprang up a few years ago Japan has seen
an explosion of urban petting zoos with
an ever more exotic cast of critters
life in the big city can be pretty tough
sometimes so when people in Tokyo want
to wind down they get wound up in the
friendly coils of a Kunis hairy rat
snake like taisho the snake charmed are
mostly young and female for owner heesu
meet sue koneko serving up drinks with a
side of hissing reptiles as a personal
calling rock song I was born in the year
of the snake he said my mother always
said I resemble a snake because I have a
poker face headlining in Yokohama is the
copy bada a rodent the size of a
Labrador Placid capybara jumps for its
morning bad but generally does little
except munch and snooze still patrons
pay for the privilege of feeding it
kibble and grubbing the docile creature
the wrong way as it prefers a long John
nickel time these are cuter than cats or
dogs at
handler Akihiko tani Waukee petting them
is so relaxing in the increasingly
competitive animal cafe market coffee
and cute animals alone just doesn't cut
it anymore
enter hedgehogs and dollhouses complete
with bathtubs paintings in a candy store
the slumbering mounds of prickles not
only seem oblivious to their designer
digs they can be downright house
wreckers the cafe turns a profit by
selling accessories like Hedgehog head
we're putting on Gundam night I think
once they get used to people hedgehogs
don't get their bristles ups a toner
Yoshiaki cotta hito but by far one of
the most lucrative of Japan's new breed
of animal cafes features bandana wearing
Shiba dogs drawing hundreds of patrons 7
days a week
the mommy Shiba cafe is so mobbed
critics accuse it of animal abuse
charges the company insists are
unfounded of course the dogs would get
stressed out if they worked non-stop
sits staff member Saudi Kikuchi so we
bring them out in shifts and give them
breaks one thing is clear this country
is happily going to the dogs for CBS
this morning Saturday
Lucy Kraft Tokyo happily going to the
dog for the Hedgehog I think the
Hedgehog one crossed a line for me but
I'll take the dogs exactly a looking
animal for me is the copy of the neutral
there's a copy bara I like that he looks
like a nutrient in Louisiana that's a
that's not a good thing just a copy bar
I could he's right there is Ryder no
Swiper cafes we talked about by now